I feel like I look like what your dad
looked like in high school it's been an
acute season so everyone's trying to get
hard it's some super o'clock time to get
wet it's summertime step ones worry
about their tight bonds and tight [ __ ]
you see the title of this video here's
what girls think about when they work
out not really what girls think about
when they work out but more what I think
about when I work out I know any of you
relate to any of this well should I
dress too sexy I'm going to be over
sexualized at this gym headphones in so
we can't hear how people react to the
fact that we breathed weird to my 10
bunch of mom I'm not new let's take a
warm-up song Instagram Instagram
Instagram and we're at the gym oh this
looks like a spaceship I'm bored
do it for potato this is a stretch if I
sit here long enough and we're going oh
my God look normal I'm bored let's
change up the song gram gram gram gram
we're in a jam my tampon to song I'm
going to be I'm sorry me walking on this
treadmill so people think I have a
healthy balance cool productive
lifestyle they got prank so hard I'm so
bored how do arms work when you're
walking and the quickly touch my crotch
make sure that it is to it not urine
we're good up didn't shave my armpits so
now we walk like this someone will think
this is yoga Pilates don't fart don't
fart don't fart lots of people cry at
the gym my table just fall out for
where's Sam from Clarissa explains at
all holding in parts the same as doing
Kegel I'm exercise how do we look normal
smile smile smile we are healthy my
tampon just ah we did I put a tampon in
oh my god did I put too much am poses oh
my god dwive TSS this has to be TSS I
feel like I'm following blood oh no
psych I'm running wall Ansel Elgort is
23 very cool so is exercising we've been
doing it the whole time oh my god my
pants no your inertia pens you're fine
we just gotta get back on this treadmill
we did it don't fart on front door
Hunter that's a new smell here come new
endorphins I can do anything up [ __ ]
[ __ ] slow I broke all of my toes England
is my city well that's a new crevice
well there you go that's a girl thing
about when they work out do you feel
educated I feel tired if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up and if you
want me to do more videos like this let
me know any suggestions you have in the
comment
down below and subscribe to this YouTube
channel click the subscribe button click
that little bell to get notified because
they make videos Monday Wednesday to
Friday sometimes I sometimes I don't I
don't know it's speedo season let's dip
it in it stretch your underwear season
again time to get hot it's time for swim
trunks badonkadonk and getting fun sorry
that they're all winners